former Los Angeles Ram Notre Dame legend
stop it turn it off
this is still my damn show okay
and representing I never thought I'd say
this about Jerome Bettis or anybody
representing the Land O'Lakes farmable
one JB 36 how are you Jerome
I am great and thanks for the fight zone
rich I know that was right yeah
definitely not as you know III rent Rudy
hoping he pops a quad at the end it's
true it's not a Mike come on
Rizzy really Jerome he didn't really do
that right they didn't really carry him
off right I mean come on that's a true
story what they carried him over in
their whole team they carried him off
the field man yes
were you there I was not okay
all right Jerome let's let's let's hop
right into it here what concerns you
about the Steelers playoff run this year
what concerns me is Antonia Browns hell
you know they they still haven't had all
of their their core guys healthy for a
playoff run yet and you know you hope
that Antonia brown is healthy because
you know this this is a really really
special football team and they got a
chance something you look at they played
the Patriots you know really close they
close the gap you know if Antonio Browns
healthy it presents a bigger problem and
then you know maybe that's what they
need to get over the hump
you just don't know but the one thing
that you hope is that you can find out
with all the guys healthy and when it
all comes down to it JB who would you I
got to give you one guy to name the most
valuable player on that team who would
it be
Antonia bone yeah because we well when
you look at early in the season
Ben was was rusty he was having a rough
go of it
lady I'm bail was extremely rusty he had
played preseason one guy who was
constant uh was Antonio Brown martavis
Bryant he was he he was just getting his
sea legs back under him he you know been
gone year so he and talk about was the
one guy who every week was making things
happen so I think when you look at it
you got a give and turn around a night
man a running back given the receiver
than not over someone like a on bail I
hate to do it but early in the season
lay beyond you know he and Tony Brown
was carrying a team which is rare well
look and speaking of rare as Jerome
Bettis joins me here in the Rich Eisen
show we all know the way you left the
game is a rarity right that you get to
win a Super Bowl let alone in your
hometown I mean ed Reed had this similar
career ender as well but he did play a
couple more years after after his Super
Bowl so you you left in a rare way that
said let's just say you're with the
Steelers you want to continue playing
they say to you we're not gonna give you
any more snaps and release you would you
have gone to play for the Patriots
should that have happened that was my
only option and I knew that I would get
an opportunity to play and like you know
they needed a power back they didn't
have anything and that yes I would have
I would have went against the family
wishes and I would have gone to New
England to play because at the end of
the day I'm I'm a football player and I
want to play in meaningful games and if
they're going to give me an opportunity
to play in meaningful games if they want
me to have to window dressing just to
piss off some people didn't know I don't
want to be a part of that but if you
want to allow me to play and have an
impact that's what I want to do so why
do you think there's
many hard feelings about James Harrison
because it's the Patriots no simple it's
big it's the Patriots you know the one
team that still has to struggle to be
historically and that's the one team
that he goes to so obviously there's
going to be some some bad feelings
because of the struggle to beat that
team in that fact that you know they're
the dred Patriots from the standpoint of
Steeler fans and and and distill
organization in terms of the one team
they want to beat badly it's the
Patriots and they haven't been able to
beat it Jerome Bettis Pro Football Hall
of Famer here on the Rich Eisen show and
let's fast-forward to February March
April do you think Big Ben this is his
final run here or is he on the farm one
year plan just talk about it and then
come back I think I think he'll come
back I just think the the group of
receivers and and and and offensive line
and the team that he has around him it's
so rare to have all of that firepower to
have it that often and that long and I
think for him to have another year of
that you know hopefully if Bell is back
I think that that's enough to keep him
at the very least one more season and
then you know finalists were named for
the Pro Football Hall of Fame some
gentlemen will be fortunate to be in
that bust room with you shortly I you
know I don't want to talk about them
right now I want to hit on Frank Gore do
you think he's a hall-of-famer what do
you think you know the unfortunate part
is you know he played for a team that
latter part of his career they didn't
you know didn't have much success and
you know weren't in the playoffs but I
mean he had some some memorable playoff
games and he was able to impact the game
so I mean he was a tremendous player for
a long time he put thing you put if you
got to give him a nod I agree
you down a peg on the old-time Russian
list he won over 14 thousand yards in
week seven you know that's the
conversation and and I gotta be honest
you heard a lot about that prior to you
winning your Super Bowl
there's the longevity and the yards and
you know where's the ring
and I thought you you you must have
heard a lot about that sort of
conversation I did I did you know and
and and what I was would mean I wanted
to show people that you know show me a
guy that you know 250 plus that has the
the type of career that I had and I mean
you can't show me one and I think that
was I was trying to point out the
uniqueness of who I was as a football
player I just think you know we need to
investigate his career a little more I
think the unfortunate part about you
know this process is so many times
nobody investigates somebody's career
and look at the success that they had
and why did they have that success and
what was it a correlation to and look at
look at these type of things to see if
you can get a true idea of who that
player was because if you didn't follow
Frank Gore if you didn't follow the
49ers then you're just looking at a guy
saying hey he's got a lot of yards but I
don't think he did much other than that
and I think that would be a gross
understatement
for for a player that had so much
success in his career
all right JV Jerome Bettis here in the
Rich Eisen show what is the Land O'Lakes
farm bowl what is this all about what do
you got for me the Land O'Lakes farm
bowl it's a it's a challenge what we
what we're going to do is going to be a
lot of what we're going to have some
retired and active NFL players and we're
going to team up with some Land O'Lakes
farmers and what we want to do is we're
going to get involved in a lot of farm
themed challenges and we want to compete
and really the idea is is one to show
that the the farming industry and the
technology that's a
and that this is an industry that has
evolved that is is now from a technology
standpoint or in the forefront
indifferent in that industry they're
using drones I mean they're using self
driven tractors so they're doing a lot
in terms of technology that no one even
knows about but there's also a lot of
careers that are available here in that
sector and I think that's a part that
you know a lot of people don't know
about so you just try to bring a lot of
people the awareness that that that's
out there that that's available and what
what better way to do it and in
Minneapolis we're going to be at the
University of Minnesota's their hockey
arena and it's gonna be a ton of fun
it's going to be free and we just
looking forward to we think it's going
to be a great time
that's the Thursday afternoon one
o'clock one two three and if anybody
wants to to you know read up more about
it or look more into it then go to the
farm Bolcom and get get more information
about it okay and I just shoroma
I don't know I think they told me to
tell you this is breaking news they're
no longer having it indoors at the
hockey arena it's going to be outdoors
at the University of Minnesota football
stadium oh yeah they just told that to
me in my ear so congratulations enjoy
the farm ball free I want to see you
there you don't be on my team dress
dress appropriately
okay I'll be part of the drone drop
that's what I'll be or the feed run
that's what I'll be part of that's
exactly love you Jerome thanks for
calling I will chat say hey you gotta
that's Jerome Bettis so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience